[Music]
on this Sunday night Israel's prime
minister makes it Crystal
Clear we will fight until a complete
Victory the message to refugees in
central Gaza and the escalating threats
along the border giving the gift of Life
didn't take no time it didn't hurt the
plea from Canadian Blood Services to
meet an important goal and they couldn't
make light of it it was the
disappointing what could revive a Quebec
couple's bright and beautiful tradition
robbed by
rodents global national with forign
Asser reporting tonight n Gara good
evening and thanks for joining us
Israeli Prime Minister Benjamin
Netanyahu is dismissing reports the US
has convinced Israel not to expand its
military offensive in
Gaza Israel is a sovereign state
Netanyahu told his cabinet today our
decisions are not dictated by external
pressures Israel is reporting one of its
deadliest stretches in Gaza with 14
soldiers killed in the territory since
Friday as McKenzie gray reports that
hasn't slowed the offensive with dozens
of Palestinians reported killed in fresh
Israeli strikes across the
strip there's no Christmas break in the
Israel Hamas conflict as smoke billows
across Gaza
and on the ground more deaths the latest
Israeli strike hitting a refugee camp in
central Gaza the Associated Press
reporting at least 60 people were
killed this man from Gaza City followed
the Israeli instruction and headed south
now he says his grandson daughter and
son-in-law are all
dead it's all targeting civilians we are
all Targets there is no safe place
creating the injured is also becoming
increasingly difficult according to the
World Health Organization only nine of
gaza's 36 hospitals are even partially
functional after 246 registered attacks
on Healthcare infrastructure across the
territory hospitals are protected under
International humanitarian law but the
Israelis contend hamas's used Healthcare
facilities to carry out their own
attacks and the patients inside them are
used as human
Shields Israeli leadership is signaling
no changes in sight we will continue to
fight until the total victory over Hamas
said prime minister Benjamin Netanyahu
but Hamas isn't the only threat
Netanyahu sees order skirmishes with
Lebanese based Hezbollah have also
stepped up with explosions taking place
on both sides of the Border Iran backs
the Lebanese
group and also houthi rebels in Yemen
who've been attacking commercial ships
in the Red Sea leading every major
shipping company to stop using the key
global trade route the most important
thing in the southern part of the
Arabian Peninsula is is the movement of
uh oil and and natural gas through the
Gulf of Aiden and up the Red
Sea us says they shot down four houthi
drones as a part of a multinational Navy
force in place to patrol the area the
additional protection now leading
shipping Titan MK to announce they
return to the region returning home for
hundreds of thousands in Gaza isn't
possible 1.9 million people 85% of the
population already displaced according
to the UN agency for Palestine refugees
and with so many on the move it's often
left to children to search for food and
water just to survive another day
McKenzie Greg Global News
Ottawa this week marks one year since
the Taliban banned women in Afghanistan
from attending postsecondary schools
it's part of a wider Crackdown on
women's and girls rights in the country
to escape all of this a growing number
of female Afghan students are seeking
Scholarships in Canada but as shagufa
donish reports there are a lot of
roadblocks and not many
spots Zahra rajab is teaching herself
English and applying for scholarships
abroad she has no hope of returning to
University in Afghanistan I had a lot of
ambition and also uh dreams and plans
reibi was studying to become a
journalist but just a few weeks into her
first sem the Taliban banned women from
higher
education one year later she is
desperate to find a way to learn even if
that means leaving they cannot stop our
life we try to um continue our life and
to until to catch our big Ambitions
while the 20-year-old from kabell is
determined the situation is growing more
difficult for hundreds of of thousands
of Afghan women and girls deprived of a
right to learn hadan nid was in her
second here of engineering at Kell poly
Technic University when classes shut
down stuck at home she is depressed over
what she calls the taliban's mission to
destroy women why we cannot decide it um
for our future and uh this me U very sad
the nonprofit organiz ization Canadian
women for women in Afghanistan which
advocates for women and girls in
Afghanistan is creating paths for those
desperate to learn what we came up with
was asking higher education institutions
in Canada so colleges and universities
here um to do what they could to respond
things like opening up their programs to
women in Afghanistan to attend virtually
allowing them to transfer into their
program even if Afghan women complete
courses online there are no career
prospects women are banned from going to
work so getting out is their only option
Canada has settled 40,000 Afghan
refugees in the past two years but eight
organizations say getting a student visa
can be like winning the lottery shugu
FES Global News
adawa in Quebec the search for a
4-year-old girl who fell into a river
north of Quebec city is in its Third Day
police say a mother and her daughter
were sledding near the bank of the MBI
River when the child slipped through a
safety barrier and fell into the water
the incident happened Friday afternoon
search efforts by foot and drone are
underway three more Quebec public sector
unions say they've reached tentative
deals with the province around working
conditions the unions represent some
185,000 healthcare workers and more than
12,000 educ education staff negotiations
over pay are still ongoing they're part
of a group known as the common front if
deals aren't reached they've threatened
to launch an unlimited strike with its
more than 400,000 members in the New
Year Canadian Blood Services says
there's an urgent need for donations
this holiday season the nonprofit says
the distribution of blood has outpaced
the number of donations being made this
year as Nia gangal reports it's hoping
for some 30,000 people to step up in the
coming
weeks it's the season of giving but in
the midst of all that holiday shopping
eating and traveling when it comes to
giving blood it's easy to forget
Canadians are very generous but I I
think they also get distracted Canadian
Blood Services is calling for 30,000
people to donate blood between now and
January 7th hospitals keep running
patients cancer patients keep undergoing
surgery unfortunately people still get
into car accidents and have traumas so
the need for blood doesn't go away since
blood is a perishable product it's not
like we can collect a bunch of it
throughout the year put it in a
warehouse and pull it out when we need
it earlier this month Health Canada
lifted a ban on blood donations related
to madcow disease after nearly 30 years
now that means thousands more Canadians
are now eligible to give blood just in
time for the holiday season we've seen
hundreds and hundreds of new donors come
in in fact 20% of the new donor since
December 4th have been as a result of
that change in criteria 82-year-old Bill
Cosman first gave blood in
1961 this Christmas he is making his
227th blood donation I felt it was an
obligation something was easy to do
didn't take no time it didn't hurt and I
had lots time to be able to do it I kept
going many collection centers are open
through the holidays including Boxing
Day and New Year's Day I would encourage
you younger people to come it's very
easy and the blood is much needed n
Gangi Global
News looking back on months of horror
coming up the global news team reflects
on covering the Israel Hamas
War it's been nearly 3 months since
Hamas Unleashed its surprise attack in
southern Israel prompting Israel to
proceed with its unrelenting mission to
destroy Hamas Global News teams have
been on the ground covering the war and
some of the things they've seen and
heard are Unthinkable a warning that
some of the reporting includes graphic
content without warning violence and
Chaos erupts in the Middle East at dawn
local time Hamas militants launched an
unprecedented and large scale surprise
attack far gun battles continue t night
on Israeli territory after an attack
that people here are now calling
Israel's
9/11 we landed we found a country that
was absolutely terrified and shock the
air raid sirens were
constant the Iron Dome is doing its
job just a ton of explosions happening
all around us then one Hamas rocket made
it
through
I feel the most vulnerable uh I've ever
felt in my life one of the first people
we spoke to was at that music festival
where hundreds were murdered and they
just described some of the most horrific
scenes I've I've ever heard about the
October 7th attack really impacted
almost every Israeli every day we were
just overwhelmed by
grief her funeral was delayed by 30
minutes because the MERS couldn't be
sold I don't think I've ever seen
anything quite like what Hamas did on
October the 7th the entrance to the thae
worker safe room in kibuts near o feels
like a moment Frozen in time while Hamas
militants went on a rampage some of the
workers sought Refuge here but instead
they were slaughtered they didn't just
invade Israel and and kill people there
was a level of humil
every day we were hearing some of the
most horrific stories I've ever heard
things that you didn't think that humans
were capable of doing to other humans
Israel is used to fighting Wars but not
like this one 4 days after the deadliest
attack in decades Israel is preparing
for a possible ground defensive in
Gaza Gaza is under
siege Israeli Rockets rain down on the
Palestinian City bringing death and
destruction we were still you know so
caught up in in the aftermath of this
horrific attack in Israel and then
suddenly you know are simultaneously
turning our attention to the bombardment
of
Gaza everything
without ask or giving you hear now there
is a bumping the ones that stick in your
head are the ones where they're pulling
kids out of the rubble and they're just
covered in white
dust the Israeli Army has now Advanced
further into The
Enclave Israel has given Palestinian
civilians a choice flee now or get
trapped in the north where violence has
and will continue to
escalate we connected with this
Palestinian freelance journalist in Gaza
named aiz aiz was our eyes and ears on
the ground in Gaza civilian defense is
of the fire and the images that he got
it just looked like the end of the
world another survival aiz went from
being the means of our coverage to being
the subject of it I try to evacuate my
house my uh children look my
family all of them like this please send
this message to International Community
the bombing escalated and he would send
us these voice notes these videos
overnight showing us telling us what was
happening and it was
harrowing a lights thrown by Israelis on
the Eastern of uh Kaza Eastern of
jabalia camp it was pitch
dark as you listen now they targ get
something here's footage the IDF says
shows civilians walking South following
the evacuation order thankfully aiz and
his family eventually got
out Vivian silver was somebody who lived
for peace and she walked the walk her
whole
life she organized this March in the
West Bank in 2017 condemning an earlier
Israeli attack on Gaza civilians where
we've been told that only war will bring
peace we don't believe that anymore this
is what is left of viven Silver's house
I visited her home in kabut ble and it
was burned beyond recognition and in the
end she lost her life to the hatred she
tried to stop gazi Hamed a member of the
political Bureau of Hamas spoke with our
crystal ganing in Beirut that was a a
tense moment you just have to remind
yourself stay calm stay calm taking the
the women and the children and the
elderly was that a mistake look uh I
think this is not what Our intention it
is not our intention to to
civilians despite those claims more than
1,400 Israelis were killed in the
October 7th attack and there was a lot
of misinformation flying around this
story and I can tell you having seen it
with my own eyes the Palestinians were
shot in the West
Bank I can tell you having talked to the
victim's families that civilians were
killed on October the 7th even though
some people would tell you that they
weren't you don't have to pick a side in
this conflict to be sad about how people
are going through it this installation
is called lights of Hope standing in the
middle it's a little like being
surrounded by bright candles and strands
of light but it is something to see as
the sun goes down here in
Jerusalem the gray Grinch ahead a Quebec
coup's battle against a hairy Critter
dimming their holiday
[Music]
lights a beloved Quebec Christmas tree
around for decades recently went dark to
the disappointment of many but as Dan
Spectre explains the community the tree
gave so much joy to has given its owners
a
surprise in the Montreal suburb of dval
the Christmas lights on the glant
Family's 70ft Tall Pine are the stuff of
Legend since 1981 Robert Galant has been
decking it out he'd even get up on a
crane to do the top it was so bright you
could see it from an airplane pretty
spectacular I every year my kids and I
would drive by to look at that tree but
the past few years it's gone almost
entirely dark in this case the Grinch is
gray and has a bushy tail it's no longer
feasible because there's too many
squirrels since 2017 the squirrels just
won't stop biting through the wires
Robert fought the good fight in some
cases renting the crane again to replace
the nod lights only to have them go dark
again he even tried to as he describes
it evict them by traing ing the critters
and moving them elsewhere I did
282 a year and a half and last year I
started with 10 and my wife said
stop but the joy the tree spread to the
neighborhood was just given back to the
galance in a way they never expected a
clever engineer who liked the Finer
Things in life was looking for a
Christmas gift to please his lovely wife
their neighbor Catherine Hanley who' had
a row seat for the whole Saga had
secretly been writing and illustrating a
children's book all about it she gifted
it to the glance just before the
holidays it was a complete surprise it
and it really did bring tears to my eyes
it was it was really special and I felt
so gratified that they took the time to
examine every page and and appreciate
the thought that went into it it was
perfect Henley thought this was a way to
memorialize the tree but it's actually
reignited Robert's desire to possibly
give it another try Christmas spirit
Never Dies an outpouring of neighborly
love sparked by one family's diligent
desire to spread joy to their Community
Dan Spectre Global News
Montreal a global national Christmas Eve
tradition that's a tough competition
next some of your pets decked out for
the
holidays and that is global national for
this Christmas Eve which means we're
about to lighten things up you've waited
all year for it our third annual
compilation of our viewers pets from
dogs to donkeys dressed up in their best
festive outfits if your pet made the cut
congratulations if not well there's
always next year on behalf of Donna far
and the entire team here at global
national have a very Merry Christmas
I'll see you back here tomorrow have a
wonderful
[Music]
night la la la la la la la la la la la
la
la la la la la
[Music]
la
w
[Applause]
[Music]
a
wait a second wait a minute coming with
the S to the family Merry Christmas
Happy New Year to my f b the ringing
children singing all together young and
old how you like
that cookie smelling up the house apple
pie on the St get the Coco for your mama
and theet for the cold come on tell
meing
CER I
like think I'm ready for night show
Street all around I can't beack out real
nice tree on the ground it might be me
might be mine holiday f s after song
It's a qu want to switch it up put a
remix on it only way I'mma sing it this
time I'm sing it like we wish you a
Merry
Christmas we wish you a Merry
Christmas and a Happy New
Year happy
[Music]
holid happy
holid